Good afternoon, everybody. We
waited a little bit, thinking we might get more,
but we are very thrilled that you're here, and we promise you a
very good session. So today, we will be talking
about, does adherence to oral cancer therapy matter?
Just a brief overview of adherence.
We define it as an active, collaborative choice to follow
a treatment plan. About $100 to $300
billion
can be due to poor adherence, and these are
avoidable costs. They're estimated to exceed $500 billion.
Ten to 25% of all hospitalizations are due to poor
adherence. About 125,000 preventable
deaths due to non-adherence occur in the United
States each year. And then in terms of chronic
health condition management, about 50% of the patients
with chronic diseases do not take their medications as prescribed.
Now, when we bring it back to oncology,
as of January 2026, we know that there are
145 approved oral chemotherapy drugs.
So people have to self-administer those drugs
in semi-chronic fashion. And oral
drugs, looking into the future, are making up more than
30% of the oncology treatment development pipeline.
So as this portfolio of
self-administered cancer treatments grows,
there needs to be an investment in adherence
research, and that would pay large dividends.
What the goal should be when we're focusing on adherence research,
the goal should be in understanding the prevalence, the patterns, the
predictors of poor adherence, and in then developing effective,
scalable, and disseminable adherence-enhancing interventions.
These can have far-reaching effects on
improvement in relapse-free survival
for a variety of cancers. So without further ado,
I'm going to have
our session speakers present on this topic
with a wide variety of flavor. We have Dr.
Rita Hayes talking about breast cancer adherence
to oral agents in breast cancer,
Dr. Morris talking about colorectal cancer and adherence to drugs,
and then I will talk about childhood acute lymphoblastic
leukemia. So with that,
what we want to do today is to make sure that we finish our presentations
first, and then would like to take all the questions, thus
ensuring that you all stay in the room till the end of the session.
So,
Dr. Rita Hayes.
Thank you so much. I'm Katherine Reeder-Hayes.
I'm a breast oncologist and a health services researcher at the University of North
Carolina Lineberger, and I'm so appreciative to
Dr. Bachia and the meeting organizers for inviting me to talk today
about a long-term interest of our lab,
and that is breast cancer
oral therapy adherence, and particularly as it
pertains to long-term oral endocrine therapy.
So I always like to point out that breast oncologists were really the first
users of targeted therapy in cancer,
from 1896 when Dr. George Bateson
described the phenomenon of regression of locally
advanced breast tumors after oophorectomy in young women.
And this observation eventually led to the isolation
of the estrogen receptor at the University of Chicago in the
1950s on mammalian breast cells, and
then to the original assays, steroid binding assays, and then
later immunohistochemical tests to identify estrogen
receptor expression on breast cancers and
therefore serve as a predictive biomarker of this response to this
targeted therapy.
And today, later generation endocrine therapies still are a
cornerstone of systemic therapy for hormone receptor-positive breast
cancer, which makes up about 78% of cases in the
United States, with rising proportions.
And that means that it is now an indicated therapy for about a quarter
of a million new cases of breast cancer diagnosed each year in the
United States, primarily with curative intent.
And when taken as prescribed, endocrine therapy, even though it's
just a pill, as our patients often say, does substantially
cut the risk of breast cancer recurrence by up to 50% and the risk
of breast cancer death by one-third.
And that is certainly a major contributor to the drop
in breast cancer mortality rates that we have observed in the United States
since the introduction of adjuvant tamoxifen in the early mid-1980s.
And as Dr. Bachia referenced earlier, we've really seen an
escalation in oral cancer therapy drug approvals
generally, but certainly in endocrine therapy in the past two
decades. And with the exception of the injected SERD fulvestrant,
all of our novel endocrine therapy drug approvals in the past 20
years have come in pill form. And as
the pace of these approvals has escalated, we've
also seen an increasing number of agents that are used as part of
doublets and used on more complex schedules versus
just the good old once-a-day of the aromatase inhibitors and
tamoxifen. And looming on the horizon, we have the predicted
approval of the oral SERD jiradecirant in the adjuvant
setting. That will be our first oral SERD approved for early-stage breast
cancerI'm assuming the approval proceeds.
And as you can imagine, these novel therapies are many, many
times more costly, particularly when they come in novel
doublets compared to earlier generation therapies.
And extending geo-destined to the early-stage setting will
increase that cost burden further manyfold simply
because of that 250,000 number I showed you earlier.
So endocrine therapy is really a case study for all of the different kinds of
challenges that we see with medication adherence in chronic disease
due to its duration of therapy, usually recommended for no less than five
years, a substantial side effect burden across multiple organ
systems, and patient understandings of both the risks and the
benefits of the drug that often differ from the clinician's
evidence-based understanding. Drug costs and access to the
newer agents, as I mentioned, is a problem, in addition to the problems
that all of us have when we try to do anything over and over again every
day with forgetting doses.
A unique problem that we have in breast cancer is the position of this oral
therapy. It comes at the end of a very long treatment cascade for
most patients that includes surgery, chemotherapy,
possibly radiation, possibly breast reconstruction.
And then at the end, just as they're celebrating being over all this
intensive therapy, they are handed a pill and told that this is also an important
part of their treatment. And psychologically, that's really a very
difficult
starting point for great adherence.
And in addition, we don't have any reliable biomarkers of, for
instance, drug levels in these medications, and so we are relying on
indirect and patient-reported measures of adherence.
So we've known for about 15 years now, thanks to the pioneering work of
Don Hershman and the Kaiser Permanente system in Northern California,
that we have a substantial real-world problem with adherence to
these drugs. And Don found that
among Kaiser patients who are uniformly insured in an
integrated health system, people who we would think might be the most
well-resourced in terms of having high adherence to their
medications, only about 60%
of patients with female breast cancer in this system were continuing to take their
drugs and adherent at a threshold of 80% over their five
years of therapy.
And Dr. Hershman's findings led our group to become interested
in the specific question of whether racial differences in
medication adherence could be an explanatory factor in the very
persistent and very pronounced racial gaps in the survival,
specifically of hormone receptor-positive disease that we've
observed in the United States ever since about 30 years
ago when tamoxifen was introduced.
And so we started with multi-payer claims data as well.
We looked at younger commercially insured women and found that, in fact, there
was a substantial racial gap,
first in the initiation of any kind of endocrine therapy, and that that
gap appeared to be concentrated among women who had been previously
treated with chemotherapy as part of their treatment plan.
And then looking at adherence among those who did initiate, we
again found in younger Black women a gap
in medication adherence, measured by medication possession
ratio for Black women under 65, which was not
present among the Medicare-age
population. And one detail that I've really gone back
to over and over again over time, thinking about interventions, is
that the patterns of non-adherence were also different by
race. Young Black women tended to have more of what I call spotty adherence,
so frequent small gaps in medication supply.
And if you think as a clinician, and you're thinking about the kinds of ways that
you might detect a patient having challenges with adherence, such
as pharmacy refill alerts, those are going to be less likely
to go off for a patient who is having frequent problems with some
missed doses as opposed to one big discontinuation or pause.
We have also used national data from Treatment MarketScan to do some of this work.
And I wanted to insert this graphic here just to
highlight that when we define adherence by a
dichotomous threshold, even if it's a clinically rational
dichotomous threshold, we are often missing some
of the granularity and meaning in the story.
And so using trajectory modeling, we've been able to identify
more different patterns of adherence, including people who are super
adherent, people who have a little bit of a decline over time but mostly stay on
track, and people who have a pretty sharp and sudden decline
shortly after initiating the medication.
But the two groups I wanted to call your attention to here are the
steady declining group in the light blue, and then this group in the
purple that has a similar early decline but then has
what I call a rescue or recovery trajectory.
So as interventionists, I think that should get us
thinking, "Okay, who are this group of people?
What is their story?
What are they experiencing that's different that allows them to have a
recovery trajectory? And could we potentially support more
patients to get on a similar recovery trajectory?"
So to dig more into those kinds of factors, we turn to patient-reported
data and specifically to the Carolina Breast Cancer Study, which we were
fortunate enough to be part of data collection for between
2008 and 2013. We asked
Black and non-Black women in this study, which oversamples Black
women at 50%, about their adherence behaviors,
beliefs, and side effects at about two years
after their initial breast cancer diagnosis.
And we found, in short, that essentially every type of adherence
barrier that has been identified in medication adherence literature was more
commonly reported among Black compared to white
women.um, across a number of different domains.
And the Black women were more likely to tell us that they had a negative or
neutral attitude towards whether the benefits of their therapy
really exceeded the problems.
We asked people medication beliefs around endocrine therapy, and
Black women were also more likely to tell us two very interesting
things. First, they were more likely to perceive that their breast
cancer was at very low risk of recurrence, despite the
fact that stage and other biological data from the study suggests that
our Black participants are actually at higher risk of recurrence.
And they were also more likely to report that they believe their risk would not
change substantially if they were to discontinue the medication.
So you can imagine that a patient with this set of beliefs about both
risk and efficacy of the medication might make a very rational
decision not to persist with a drug, particularly if it was causing
them substantial side effect problems.
And using the FACT-ES instrument, we also were able to demonstrate
that in fact, these side effect problems across almost every
domain of endocrine-associated symptom that we asked about, were
also more common among our Black participants.
So this is an adherence framework being used by our group for the
last few years that summarizes some of the research from our own group and
others, based on the WHO's framework of
adherence domains in HIV, which was really the original
subspecialty field doing work in medication adherence.
And I put this here just to remind us all that this is a complicated problem,
that not every patient has the same story for why they may
be
hitting an adherence target or not hitting an adherence target.
And we can start to imagine interventions that may have to look similarly
multifaceted and complex to achieve a helpful
result for our patients.
But before we buzz on to talking about intervention,
we really need to pause and say, "Okay, not only is this problem
common, not only is it pervasive, but
is it actually important for disease outcomes?" And in breast
cancer, I think we have substantial evidence from a variety of sources that
adherence is impactful in outcomes.
So on the left here, we have the older Swedish Breast Cancer
Cooperative Group's randomized controlled trial of planned
discontinuation of tamoxifen at two years, versus the
duration that is now the standard of care for tamoxifen, five
years, demonstrating that earlier discontinuation is
impactful on disease-free survival.
And on the right, we have more data from Don Hirschman showing a dose
response relationship between lower and lower medication possession
ratios of aromatase inhibitors and tamoxifen, and the
overall survival of early-stage breast cancer patients in the Kaiser system.
So using both real-world and randomized data, I think we
can appreciate that a standard duration and a therapeutic
medication possession ratio of endocrine therapy is
impactful on outcomes. Although we will not be doing, of course, randomized
studies in this setting at this time.
And although these are immature data, I think we also have some intriguing
indicators from the Carolina Breast Cancer Study, where we have looked at the
association of race and non-adherence, where we have seen
among hormone receptor-positive and HER2-negative patients after
controlling for biological factors and their age, that adherent
patients tend to have a
similarly low risk of recurrence across
both Black and white participants.
But that the increased risk
for non-adherent participants seems to be
concentrated among Black participants.
We have a number of different hypotheses that we're investigating about why this
may be, from differences in the underlying biology of the tumor, that
perhaps require more stringent adherence in order to get the benefits of endocrine
therapy, or potential differences in the duration or the
depth of non-adherence among Black women who are not being
supported to get back on a recovery trajectory.
And so a cross-sectional moment of non-adherence turns into
a longitudinal lower effective dose.
So based on these data, I'm happy to say that this field has been
moving in the last five years from observational research to more
interventional research. And here on this slide, I have listed the
completed and ongoing randomized clinical trials of adherence
interventions in the breast cancer space.
SWOG 1105 was the first. This is Don Hirschman's trial,
looking at an unselected
breast cancer survivor population on aromatase inhibitors,
and they were randomized to usual care versus a text message reminder intervention.
This was a negative trial.
And then Ilana Graetz in the Emory network has
similarly conducted an RCT looking at a symptom
management intervention, a single mode of intervention,
again, in unselected users, and did not find an
effect of that intervention on adherence.
Although there was a signal for possible greater efficacy among the
younger participants in that study.
So there are two second-generation trials in the field currently, the
SWOG 2010 or ASPEN trial, and my group's
GETSET trial in the Alliance for Clinical Trials in Oncology.
And both of these studies focus on more selected
populations. In ASPEN, these are younger
women getting endocrine therapy that includes ovarian suppression,
which steeply increases the side effect burden.
And in GETSET, we oversample women under 50 and Black women
at 30% each. And both of these are also somewhat
more complex and high-intensity interventions
compared to the original trials.And both of these trials
are still in data collection phases.
So our GetSET study was based on a single-arm pilot of
42 women,
over-sampling Black participants in this pilot as well, and is based
on telephone-delivered motivational interviewing using the window of
opportunity of endocrine therapy initiation or the months immediately following
initiation, since we have seen a lot of early drop-off, particularly among
young women, in the first year of therapy.
And in our original pilot, we did see that
the intervention was generally acceptable and
feasible, and that we had high adherence in our cohort overall, which did
not differ by race, although, as I said, we didn't have a comparator arm in
this pilot study. And based on that and
on some work from colleagues at The Ohio State University, Electra
Paskett, Michelle Naughton, and others, who had
simultaneously been testing a text message intervention, we put
these interventions together and designed the GetSET randomized controlled
trial. It features four arms, one with text message
reminders alone. The Hirshman trial data were not available at the time we
designed this study. One with motivational interviewing and counseling
alone,
one with the combination, and an enhanced usual care arm that receives
static educational materials.
This study has closed to accrual recently.
We accrued 1,165 participants, and we
collected primary endpoint data through electronic pill cap monitoring,
and then a large variety of electronic PRO
data at three-month intervals in the cohort as well.
This was designed deliberately to be a very pragmatic, very
outside the clinic study with a diverse sample.
And although we do not have efficacy data from this trial yet, we have recently
been looking at our patient engagement data, and I was happy to see that among
530 women who were randomized to arms that involved
motivational interviewing,
92% of those randomized participants participated in at
least one session, and 81% actually participated in all
five of the MI sessions that we offered them across the
six-month intervention period. So we were happy to see that level of
engagement.
So to summarize some key takeaways, hopefully I've convinced you that
long-term use of endocrine therapy is both common and a really
multifaceted challenge for a large proportion of our breast
cancer survivors, and that it does matter for their disease
outcomes.
When it comes to medication taking in this setting and in any setting
of long-term oral therapy, one size is not going to fit all when it
comes to interventions. We need to think about how to find the folks who benefit
most from intervention. And the early trials are telling us something that really
the HIV world already knew, which is that low intervention,
low intensity, and low touch interventions, single mode interventions,
are unlikely to be effective in this space.
But some promising strategies, in my opinion, include risk stratification
of potential participants in interventions, designing
multi-component interventions with more than one evidence-based tool,
and also being able to reach patients outside the clinic.
I think those of us who are providers are very aware that we have more
unfunded mandates than we can deal with,
and that time in the clinic,
a lot of
subjects and topics and patient needs are competing for that space.
So as much as we can get out of the clinic to reach patients, I think that's going
to help the folks we want to help.
And the new challenges on the adherence horizon, both for breast
cancer and in other cancer settings, are most certainly
intensified,
longer duration, and complex multi-component
regimens. And rising cost is going to be another
challenge associated with access-driven, non-adherence that we're all going to
be facing in the clinic in the years to come.
Thanks so much for your attention.
I couldn't do this without all of my collaborators, both within my
lab and across the country, and I will take questions
at the time of the question session at the end,
when all of us have spoken.
Well, thank you so much. That was a fantastic talk,
and we will transition straight into colorectal cancer. Dr.
Meyris.
So thank you very much. I'd like to first start by thanking the AACR and the
organizing committee for the opportunity to talk on a very
patient-centric question
surrounding the adherence to oral therapies in
colorectal cancer patients. And I'll be talking about
how we're incorporating some of the technologies that we're hearing
about at this conference over the weekend to do better for our patients with this
disease.
These are my disclosures.
So I was asked to answer this question, does adherence to oral
cancer therapies in colorectal cancer matter?
And I think at first glance, the obvious answer is yes.
But as we think about what these drugs are in colorectal cancer
and how this affects the day-to-day lives of our patients and their families
who are living with this diagnosis through the journey, the question
becomes a little bit more complicated.
So to answer this question in more detail, I'm going to divide
the time, the next 20 minutes, into three major
clinical approaches we're taking at our institution to better
address adherence to oral therapies in the day-to-day management of colorectal
cancer. We'll talk about incorporating patient
feedback to minimize toxicity of
FDA-approved therapiesHow we're using circulating tumor DNA
to ensure best practices with oral therapies in colorectal cancer, and
finally, kind of some novel clinical trial approach to make sure that we're
offering best therapies to all patients
with oral therapies in colorectal cancer that are under investigation.
So I come from Houston, at MD Anderson, and as the saying goes,
"Houston, we have a problem." In 2026, colorectal cancer
is the second leading cause of death in the United
States. But under the age of 50, as you can see in the figure
on the left here, it's now the leading cause of cancer-related death under
the age of 50. For men and women and
alike in this demographic, it's the lung cancer
diagnosis for which cancer-related mortality is continuing to
increase year after year.
Because of these alarming trends, new effective therapies
are urgently needed for our patients with this diagnosis.
When we look at what's been approved over the past 20 years
for patients with colorectal cancer, you can see that
over the
past two decades, and especially within the past 10 years,
the majority of therapies which have received FDA
approvals are oral therapies.
So we have to figure out ways to help our patients
adhere to these medications in a way to improve their
outcomes.
One of the questions in preparing for this talk is, what
exactly does adherence mean? And is there a difference
between adherence and compliance?
So compliance,
in some of the research I was doing, was defined as a passive behavior.
Whatever the doctor says is what I'm going to do as a patient.
I just go by their orders. Adherence, though, is very
different. And I like to think of this as a
continuum where an oncologist is providing
the best, most informed practice
tailored to the patient at their point of need.
The patient listens to that information and accepts, "Does this
align with my personal goals of care on this journey?" And then makes the active
decision of how to execute those recommendations in the
management of colorectal cancer.
So with that said, let's talk about first how we've incorporated
patient feedback to reduce toxicity in the management,
specifically of metastatic colorectal cancer.
So I asked my team at MD Anderson, I asked my PA,
my team of pharmacists, our nurses, and I also asked
our patients in a colorectal specific
fashion, "What do you think affects adherence
to oral medications?" And a lot of answers came up,
especially from the patients that we've been asking this question in recent months.
There was a lot of this centered around
first of all, going back to the spectrum I talked about,
optimizing benefit,
recommending the best practices for our patients that are informed
by the newest and most up-to-date data.
When we're giving and offering our best as doctors to our patients,
this engenders trust in our patients to
trust the recommendations that we're recommending them.
And should the patient decide, then the question becomes,
what are the toxicities and side effects of these
medications? How does this affect my quality of life?
And based on where I am in this journey, does this align with my
goals of care?
The reason that I keep harping on this point is when we look at drugs which have
been approved in the past 10 years, specifically oral therapies for
colorectal cancer,
you can see that the difference or improvement in overall
survival for these FDA-approved drugs is on the
order of one and a half to three and a half months.
So we're barely moving the needle forward, and as I'll talk about in the
coming slides, at the expense of significant toxicity.
It really wasn't until the last
of these, which I'll talk about later in the frontline setting for BRAF-mutated
colorectal cancer, that we've seen a substantial leap in
overall survival with oral therapies.
So as we're thinking about these drugs which have been approved in the past 10
years or so,
that in the later line settings, the first trial that I want to
highlight is the Correct trial. This was a phase three trial looking at the
multi-target tyrosine kinase inhibitor, regorafenib,
in patients with treatment refractory, no other standard
therapy available, metastatic colorectal cancer.
Patients were randomized either to regorafenib at a dose of
160 milligrams daily or to a placebo.
And again, this drug got approved by the FDA with a
1.4 month, a six-week improvement in overall
survival. So it was a step forward.
However, it came at the expense of significant
toxicity. As you can see in the first bullet point here,
patients were more likely than not to experience
at least one grade three treatment-related adverse
event, many of which were very physically
limiting hand foot syndrome, oral mucositis as well,
to such a fashion that taking the drug and the side effects
associated with regorafenib did not improve their
quality of life any more than those patients who were getting the
placebo for which the cancer was continuing to grow.
So you look at this and say, for six
added weeks of survival at this level of toxicity, can
we do better? Our patients certainly deserve
that.So this was a very patient-centric
trial that looked to address this question.
Following the approval of regorafenib,
patients were randomized, the same trial population, to either regorafenib
at the FDA-approved dose here or a personalized dose
escalation fashion where they started at a 50% dose reduction.
If they tolerated that after week one, they escalated to the
75% dose reduction, and then, if tolerated
by week three, to the full dose. And then their treatment was informed moving
after with whatever the best-tolerated drug
level was in that personalized approach.
And what the authors reported was significant improvement
in overall toxicity,
improvement in quality of life, while not compromising
survival outcomes for these patients.
So again, incorporating the patient experience into the real-world
practice has helped to improve the day-to-day management
of this drug in patients with colorectal cancer.
Lonserf with bevacizumab also received an FDA
approval
within the past five years for, again, a marginal
improvement in overall survival relative to
Lonserf alone. Again, so a three-month improvement, but a
similar, though not as bad story with regorafenib.
You can see here that the combination led to
significant levels of grade 3 or higher
neutropenia with this combination, such that about
30% of patients require growth factor support.
So the same question has come up. Can we do better to
manage and improve the tolerability of this regimen,
which is commonly regarded as the accepted third-line regimen for
patients with a diagnosis of metastatic colorectal cancer?
This is how it's currently given. The FDA approval says days one to
five and days eight to 12 of a 28-day cycle, which is very
confusing to a non-healthcare provider.
But the bevacizumab is given every two weeks.
So
simply by adjusting when the second week of the
Lonserf is given to align it with the dosing of the
bevacizumab,
real-world analyses have shown that you can significantly improve
upon rates of treatment-related neutropenia, reduce the need for
growth factor support, and,
again, not compromise overall survival.
So this is a very, again, patient-friendly way to improve upon
these drugs which lead to marginal improvements in survival.
So now let's move to use of circulating tumor DNA and how
we're incorporating this into the management for our patients
with
newly diagnosed metastatic colorectal cancer.
So I spent the previous part talking about these later lines of therapy, where
we're seeing only a couple of months of improvement in survival.
Last year, with the BREAKWATER data, which I'll talk about in
several slides, we saw a doubling of overall survival for
patients with BRAF-mutated colorectal cancer by bringing
oral therapies into the frontline for this disease.
Now, BRAF V600E-mutated colorectal cancer
is characterized by a very unique biology relative
to its BRAF wild-type counterpart, and that comes as
well with a very poor prognosis and probably the poorest
prognosis subgroup of the metastatic colorectal population.
BRAF and MEK inhibitors, which have very good activity
in other BRAF V600E-mutated solid tumors like
melanoma and non-small cell lung cancer, do not work
well as oral therapies. Same mutation, same
drugs, different diagnosis in colorectal cancer
in the management of this disease.
And in a really nice bench-to-bedside model, in
vitro work had shown that blocking a BRAF
V600E with a BRAF inhibitor in a
CRC-specific fashion leads to upregulation
of EGFR, which can then, of course, be blocked by
anti-EGFR therapies. This was then translated into a
positive Phase 3 trial led by my colleague, Dr.
Scott Kopetz, at MD Anderson. In the BEACON trial, this
was a second-line trial and beyond for patients with
BRAF-mutated colorectal cancer, led to an FDA approval of
encorafenib and cetuximab. But again,
the drugs worked in only 20% of
the cases.
Median progression-free survival was only four months.
This, however, was the springboard for the subsequent BREAKWATER trial
which looked to move BRAF-targeted oral therapies to the
frontline setting. BREAKWATER reported out last year.
Again, BRAF V600E metastatic colorectal cancer,
frontline of therapy. Patients were randomized to either standard of
care chemotherapy, encorafenib, cetuximab or
encoro cetux in combination with chemotherapy.
And as you can see, the study met its primary endpoints,
led to an FDA approval, but doubled survival
relative to standard chemotherapy when combined as an oral
therapy with cetuximab relative to chemotherapy alone.
We've recently seen that FULPHIRI can also be used as a cytotoxic
backbone. This also just got an FDA approval for this combination in
the past several months in the frontline setting.
But this is very, very important for our patients, because when a
patient is diagnosed with metastatic colorectal cancer,
based on the doubling of the survival, it is essential that when this
patient comes through the door, we know this information and identify this
information as soon as possible. If you take the same drugs, the same
mutation, same cancer, and look at this in different lines of
therapy, the outcomes worsen as you go to
later lines of therapy. That's why in the frontline setting,
knowing this knowledge up front is absolutely criticalAnd as
the trials evolve with KRASG12C inhibitors, HER2 neu
overexpression and probably KRASG12D, as we're hearing about
at this conference, we very much
expect that this theme will continue to expand in the years to
come. So you have to know this information.
How can we
execute best practices to ensure that our patients are
getting the best oral therapies as soon as possible?
We're doing that at MD Anderson with circulating tumor DNA.
Too often, we're hearing oncologists say, "I'll just send tissue off.
I'll wait the six weeks it takes to come back, and then I'll just switch them at
progression." That's not acceptable, and that's not what our patients deserve.
At our institution, not only can we get these tests back
within two to five business days, we feel that this is so important,
we're executing a program that when a patient establishes first
contact with our registration, we're piloting
an initiative to meet them at their home to get the blood test
so that by the time they hit the door for their first visit at MD
Anderson, we will know the BRAF, KRAS, HER2
expression status. So the answer is in the circulating tumor DNA.
I'm talking a lot now about metastatic disease, but these questions
of using ctDNA to improve oral adherence to
CRC treatments is also critical for patients in the adjuvant
setting as well. Capecitabine is a backbone of adjuvant
therapies to cure more patients when combined with oxaliplatin
with stages II and III colorectal cancer.
I won't have time to talk about this, but we've
seen aspirin as well
cure outcomes. But with
capecitabine, we've recently been mandated by the
FDA to test for DPD deficiency in all
patients who are getting either 5-FU or oral
capecitabine. So we need to have this knowledge back before the
patients start their adjuvant chemotherapy to ensure that we're
sticking to best practices. So again, to address
this, we're using the circulating tumor DNA in these patients to
identify
DPYD mutations and use that information to
tailor
treatments accordingly, dose reduce if they are
DPD deficient.
So finally, for the sake of time,
lots of oral therapies are coming out for patients with colorectal
cancer. How can we
anticipate this wave through novel clinical trial design?
We all are hearing this weekend about the role of circulating tumor
DNA as a prognostic biomarker in patients across all
solid tumors. After patients have completed standard of care
therapy with colorectal cancer, if they're found to be ctDNA
positive, we consider that a surrogate of micrometastatic colorectal
cancer with a high risk for recurrence.
Alternatively, if negative, these patients are likely to do very well
and go on to have a curative outcome.
The clinical challenge that comes with this, though, is the patient who's had their
surgery, completed their six months of FOLFOX chemotherapy, and yet is
ctDNA positive. What do we do about those patients?
And we at MD Anderson are prepared to offer patients clinical
trials for treatment of ctDNA-positive micrometastatic
colorectal cancer. I refer you to our group's
website, which features our clinical trial portfolio for
patients with ctDNA-positive micrometastatic
disease. I really want to highlight, though, a rock star in Dr.
Alicia Bent, one of our junior faculty, who has really led our oral
therapy
efforts with novel clinical trials in this setting of treating
MRT.
She first led, several years ago, a trial that we call the
DAILY trial. So the patients are ctDNA positive at very high risk for recurrence
of their colorectal cancer. Can we use
common over-the-counter oral medications like vitamin D, aspirin,
as well as exercise and diet intervention to
improve outcomes in this high-risk population?
When we compared this to a synthetic control, the answer appears that it does
appear to make a difference. So in light of some of the
recent data with celecoxib and aspirin coming out to
improve outcomes of patients with
high-risk stage II and stage III disease, we've now
activated a follow-up to her DAILY study led by Dr.
Bent, looking at lonserf with celecoxib in patients who are
ctDNA positive with colorectal
micrometastatic disease. This trial is all oral
therapies, and to better help our patients and get to more
patients, this is a completely virtual trial.
So once patients have established their care at MD Anderson, we're able to get
them set up through a novel clinical trial approach for
us to
treat patients on this clinical trial with oral therapy
approach, which we find to be very promising.
So this is how we're approaching, at MD Anderson, efforts to
improve adherence to oral medications in colorectal cancer.
As I've talked about, really listening to our patients, listening to their
experience, and refining that to personalize
drugs in the metastatic setting, making sure that we're implementing
strategies that incorporate up-to-date
standard of care practices in pharmacogenomic
profiling, and novel clinical trial design if
oral therapies are involved, creating strategies
for virtual trial participation and follow-up.
So I just want to say thank you to our wonderful team of doctors at MD
Anderson that I get to be a part of,
and I will be happy to take questions at the end of the session.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
All right. So now we're going to be talking about childhood cancer, and
I believe some people don't like childhood cancer.
So sorry.
So the topic is adherence to oral mercaptopurines in children with acute
lymphoblastic leukemia.
Just to give you an overview of why acute lymphoblastic
leukemia. One, that it is the most common childhood cancer,
accounting for a fourth of all children with cancer.
Median age at diagnosis is four years, and the male to female
ratio is 1.2:1.
Over the past several decades, there
has been a tremendous improvement in survival, such that survival
was about 10% in the '60s, exceeds 90%
now,
and continues to improve with newer drugs.
Treatment of childhood ALL includes intensive phases or
28 days of induction followed by consolidation, interim maintenance,
delayed intensification, and maintenance.
The first year is really intensive therapy.
You're in and out of the hospital, and most of the drugs are given IV.
The second phase, which is the maintenance phase, is two years long,
and it depends largely on oral administration of six
mercaptopurine.
You assess
remission at four weeks after induction, and we
know that over 95% of our children with ALL enter
in clinical remission at the end of induction, but we also
know that one in five individuals relapse
within five years.
Now,
during maintenance,
children get oral mercaptopurine once a day for two
years, self-administered.
Durable remissions indeed require that they get those two years of
maintenance.
And this has been shown very elegantly
in 1990 and has held true since then.
When you look at the area under the curve achieved by mean daily
dose of oral mercaptopurine, here are people with
high oral doses of mercaptopurine and those with lower
doses of mercaptopurine, showing that the relapse-free survival
does indeed suffer amongst those who come in remission and then are
placed on oral mercaptopurine. So disease-free
survival in children with ALL obviously depends on disease
biology, which is determined by the somatic
mutations, the chromosomal abnormalities,
and people present with high white counts,
and their age is between one and 10 years.
Sorry, less than one year and greater than 10 years.
Standard disease is one to 10 years.
And how do you monitor it? You monitor it with measurable
residual disease. So if you go into deep remission with
no measurable residual disease, you're doing well,
and the otherwise is true when you have high
MRD.
The disease-free survival also depends on
systemic exposure to oral 6-MP, as I told you, which
can be measured by leukocyte DNA-TG
levels.
This systemic exposure depends on pharmacokinetics.
It depends on dose intensity, i.e., how much are
the doctors prescribing 6-MP? Are they
giving in to the patient who says, "I want a drug holiday because I'm going for
prom,"
or are they actually maintaining that 6-MP drug intensity as
needed? And then adherence to therapy.
So our goal here was to test the
hypothesis that non-adherence results
in low systemic exposure to oral 6-MP during
maintenance, and that results in an increased risk of relapse.
And we were accounting for all the other measurable
factors on this slide.
So how did we measure it?
So the aims were obviously to measure adherence to oral 6-MP in children
with ALL, look at the impact of adherence on relapse
risk using a prospective longitudinal cohort study.
We took children who were 21 years of age or younger and were
entering into maintenance in first clinical remission.
How did we measure adherence? We measured adherence using an
electronic
track cap. These are special pill bottles where there's a
microprocessor chip in the cap that records the date and time
of opening of the medication bottle.
After six months of dispensing the medication in these bottles, we asked them
to mail the caps to us, and we downloaded the
data, and this is what the data download looks like for people who are
adherent. You can see that each blue dot represents the opening of
a pill bottle. On the y-axis is the time, so they're all clustered
within a certain period of time. And then the date
is shown here, so very few missed doses.
And this is what a non-adherent patient looks like.
So these are just visual impressions, but we also calculate the actual
dates of opening.
We measured adherence in the blood.
We measured monthly
6-MP metabolite levels, DGN and MMP, for six
times, and one-time measurement of pharmacogenetics.
We asked the patients to complete a self-report of adherence
in English and Spanish, number of days that 6-MP was taken,
number of missed doses over the past four weeks, and then barriers and
facilitators to adherence. We asked them to complete a demographic
questionnaire, race and ethnicity of the patients and their parents, parents'
education, household income, and family structure and
size.So the
sites that participated completed a maintenance
worksheet. So they filled out a calendar where they described the
prescribed dose for each day and the dates and
reasons why 6-MP was held for each of the days that it was held.
We asked the sites to complete follow-up forms for 10
years, every six months,
with details on recurrence, deaths, and second cancers.
So the patients participated for six months.
On day one, we obtained the consent or assent and
pharmacogenetics,
six monthly measurements of the 6-TGN levels,
demographic questionnaires on the first month,
and then adherence questionnaires, MEMS monitoring of
6-MP, and then download our data at the end.
So 742 children participated in this study from
94 sites across the United States.
How did we calculate adherence? We took the MEMS data and the maintenance
worksheet data, and the adherence rate was the number of days
with MEMS caps openings, divided by the number of days
that the 6-MP was prescribed. And from the denominator, we
removed the days that the 6-MP was withheld by the
physician.
This is what the cohort looked like.
Seven hundred and forty-two patients, median age at diagnosis, five years, median
age at study, six years, 68% were males, and
43% had high-risk disease. So the first question
we wanted to answer was, do children with acute lymphoblastic leukemia adhere to
prescribed chemotherapy? And this was the answer.
Overall, they start off with adherence of
95%, and it trends down to about
90% by the time they're done with the study.
And this trend is statistically significant.
We found that adolescents were less likely to
adhere compared to those who were less than 12 years of age.
We found that those who came
from houses with low income were less likely to
adhere as compared to those who came from high annual income.
Then the next question we wanted to answer was, does poor adherence to oral
6-MP influence the risk of relapse?
And here, what we did was we created five cut points
for adherence, 100%, 95%, 90%, and
85%, so on and so forth. And adjusting for all
known prognosticators of
relapse, we found that as high of an adherence
as 95% was associated with an increased risk of relapse.
So those who had an adherence rate of less than
95% had a twofold higher risk of
relapse than those who were greater than 95%
adherence. And this was true across all adherence cut points.
Looking at the cumulative incidence of relapse, here are the
non-adherers, here are the adherers.
Forty-four percent of our study participants were non-adherent.
Forty-seven percent
of the relapses could be attributed to
non-adherence to chemotherapy.
With this in mind, we said, "Let's take a look at what's the prevalence in our
socio-demographically distinct groups." And here we
show that even amongst the younger children, 41%
were non-adherers. See almost 60% amongst the older
children.
High income, low income. So the
prevalence of non-adherence was high in our population.
Why were they missing their 6-MP doses?
So here I want to take a break to tell you that children, when they
enter maintenance therapy, they're done with their hospitalizations, their
hair's growing back, they have
starting to feel all the energy that they can integrate back into
school, so they're attending all the normal school-related
activities.
6-MP has no side effects. Zero.
6-MP is very cheap. It's been there for decades.
So none of the things that we have heard from
the adult counterparts in terms of the reasons for why people would
be missing doses are generally applicable to
6-MP adherence in children. And plus, 6-MP needs
to be given for a defined duration, one and a half to two years,
once a day. So reasons for missing 6-MP, these
are self-reported reasons, and here's what we find.
And we looked at it across the age groups, the less than 12 years, 12 to
17, 18 plus.
The overwhelmingly large majority of people said they forgot to take it.
Logistic reasons were there. They realized
on the weekend that their drugs had run out and none of their
pharmacies were open,
or they were staying with their other parent in a divorce
situation, and they didn't take their medications with them.
Active refusals were very, very minimal.
Then we conducted a qualitative study where we looked at facilitators and
barriers to adherence to oral chemotherapy, and we
showed that patients and parents who were interviewed
separately,
that all of them described barriers to
medication taking. And forgetfulness was the most common
theme,
such that adherent teens and their parents
emphasized the importance of parental responsibility as a
strategy for overcoming the forgetfulness.
So the adolescents actually welcomed it, or at least held their noses
and accepted their parental vigilance.
Non-adherent teens had difficulty identifying that dyad
situation where they could have the parents be responsible for this.
So thus far, what we've learned is that 6-MP
non-adherence is prevalent.That it
increases the risk of relapse, and that there are certain
subgroups who are more likely to be non-adherent.
So we said, now there's a critical need for an
adherence-enhancing intervention. The major barrier is forgetfulness.
The major facilitator is parental vigilance.
And so with this, we developed an intervention.
The intervention package included a
multimedia interactive patient education,
web-based medication scheduling, where they got customized printed
schedule, text message reminders, and directly supervised
therapy by a designated caregiver.
This is what the multimedia interactive patient education situation looked like.
We videotaped it ourselves. We created
vignettes of patients, real patients, and their parents,
all ages, sexes, cultural, racial, ethnic
backgrounds, different SES, in English and
Spanish. And the viewer, the study participant, would
choose which patient they identified with the most
and watch that piece in the clinic. The video lasted 20 minutes.
So each patient-parent dyad was introduced by the host,
and these are the situations here. You can see them.
It was a separate video for the education arm, a separate
video for the IP arm, for different age groups in English or
Spanish. And this actor, he was a
starving actor. We filmed it in Los Angeles.
He described the benefits of 6-MP, how to overcome
the challenges, what the physician and the nurse practitioner
here are telling the patients about what happens if you don't take the 6-MP.
We had an animation.
Different for the younger kids, different for the older kids.
This is the older kids, more grunge here.
So the 6-MP tablets, the blasts are running after
those white cells and accidentally swallow a
6-MP tablet. Here, they're eating it, and then they implode.
So this is what the patients learned from here, how 6-MP
works.
That actor also provided the
IP instructions, the intervention package instructions,
told them that you will get a 6-MP schedule, which you will put on the
refrigerator. You will get a text message reminder.
The parent will work with you in swallowing the pill,
and then that would be repeated daily.
So this is what the web-based medication scheduling looked like.
It was a secure, HIPAA-compliant
application. The MD created that 6-MP schedule in
the clinic, where it is how many tablets you need to take, what
time do you need to take it, I'm prescribing it for four weeks, and this is
your start date, resulted in a schedule, which then with a
streamlined application, resulted in the patient getting a
directed message from their MD. So this message says,
"Jane, take 6-MP two tablets at 9:30 PM.
Text 1 when you have taken." Same message went to the parent.
This resulted in the parent supervising the therapy and
then both the parent and the child texting us back so that
we had a central record. Now, this was a randomized trial
across 59 sites at the Children's Oncology Group.
We randomized them into an education package and the IP
package, and we showed
that across the two arms, the IP arm
did better.
It did much better in the older patients,
where overall, there was a 4% improvement,
but amongst those who were baseline non-adherers, there was a
nine and a half percent
improvement in adherence. Younger patients did fine overall.
There was no difference in their two arms because they were
doing well anyways.
We also showed and recently published that
in the younger patients, there was no difference in relapse risk between the two
arms.
But in the older patients, the IP arm was
superior such that patients who were only in the education arm were
fivefold more likely to relapse as compared to the education
arm. So then the question is, what do we do now?
So we've shown that less than 12 years, the adherence rates are high.
They're comparable.
Older patients, the adherence rates are high in the IP arm.
So our next study needs to restrict
the intervention to only the adolescents.
We also showed that amongst those who were baseline adherers,
older patients, there was no difference between the two arms, but both
arms trended down over time. So we needed to do something to
boost up the adherence.
And amongst the non-adherers, we needed to do something to
intensify that adherence. So this is my final
slide. So we have now embarked upon a
large multi-center study.
It's across all 220 institutions.
It's across the whole two years of maintenance,
and all patients who are 12 or older undergo
12 weeks of baseline adherence monitoring.
We randomized them based on their baseline adherence rate,
adherence less than 95%, adherence greater than 95%.
Those who are non-adherers are intensified to the old IP arm.
Those who are on the ultra IP arm
get education once, but then they get boosts on their smartphones
once a month.
They get the personalized reminders as in the IP arm, but
every 15 minutes, they get a reminder
again.Until they send us the text
message back,
they get the directly supervised therapy, but we send them
back, their MDs, a report card showing
what their centralized DSD rates are.
And if they're low, they get to have a nice conversation with
their MDs.
For adherence rates greater than 95%, they're randomized to education
alone, as in the previous study. But for the other
arm, they get the education once, but we ask the patient and
parent to use their smartphones to establish
personalized reminders using their smartphones with the snooze
function, and then directly supervised therapy.
So I want to acknowledge the people who really, really contributed to the study.
Wendy Landeir, my colleague, my friend,
made those Mipe videos. She worked with the Los Angeles people.
Alice
did the analyses, and Lindsay was the master
coordinator for all the sites that participated.
I can't thank enough all the funding agencies.
Most importantly, I want to thank the kids and their parents.
They did a terrific job in participating. Thank you.
This would be the time for us to entertain
questions.
I would love to. Otherwise, I'm going to do a test on all the
people.
I can ask a question before the test.
Oh, yay.
Right. So thank you all for the excellent talks.
I've learned a great deal.
Dr. Reeder-Hayes, I'm a junior faculty breast oncologist at Mayo
Rochester, just started a few months ago,
and I have a great many discussions with patients every week about endocrine
therapy,
and so I think it's a critical topic, and I really appreciate your studies.
I wanted to ask you about the initial visit where endocrine
therapy is first discussed.
I've seen many patients who present for a second opinion,
and they feel that the topic of endocrine therapies was not introduced
well the first time around, that either they were not
given enough information, so they felt under-informed, or they
felt like they were not given a choice.
They were just told, "We are going to do this." And both the lack of
information and the lack of choice rubbed them both very much the wrong
way. And then oftentimes they'll look for information in alternative
sources like social media, so that changes their risk-benefit
perception and expectations,
and so then we're doing a lot of mop up and trying to get accurate information
afterwards.
So I was wondering, what are your comments on the importance of the initial
endocrine therapy discussion visit in regards to education and
buy-in? Do you have any recommendations to optimize this visit?
And I'd be curious if your group is researching this topic, and if so, what
efforts are you undertaking in this? Thank you.
Thanks for the question. It's a good one, and it certainly mirrors my
experience as a clinician. I will say that one of the
pieces of data I did not highlight from Carolina Breast Cancer Study was
that we asked people to describe their experience in
making the endocrine therapy decision,
and those who described it as a shared decision between themselves and their
provider were more likely to be adherent two years later
than either those who described it as entirely the
provider's decision or entirely their own decision.
So I think you're onto something there in terms of the fact that it doesn't go over
well with patients,
when what they receive is not a recommendation for therapy,
but a mandate.
So
we have not focused on clinician interventions,
because clinicians are a hard
resource intensive nut to crack. But so just from my
anecdotal experience and from the lot of qualitative data that we've collected, I
would say that a shared decision is
probably very helpful,
based on observational data,
and that quantifying risk and getting the risk
perception and the benefit perception accurate is
likely helpful because we know that a lot of people are misinformed about
both those pieces.
And in fact, I've sat with 80-year-old ladies with T1a
tumors and baseline arthritis and
osteoporosis, and we have made a shared decision
that they don't think the juice of endocrine therapy risk reduction is
worth the squeeze, and I think for many people it probably isn't.
And then I think the other thing that we need in that space is actually better
data. So I'm very excited about the low tam study coming out of
Alliance, that will randomize women with very low-risk
cancers to low-dose tamoxifen versus standard dose
tamoxifen. I'm hoping that folks will continue to
enroll to that enthusiastically. It's going really well so far.
And so I think having right fit
options for the very low-risk patient, is
something that patients want, and that we need to generate the
data to offer people right fit endocrine therapy when they are
very low risk. And then for the ones that are quite a bit higher risk,
just make sure they actually know the benefits of the drug so that they
can weigh the pros and cons accurately.
Okay, and I believe there are no questions.
Oh, there is a question here.
Hiya. Eric Fitzsimmons. I'm with "Cancer Today" magazine.
I thought it was interesting you mentioned forgetfulness.
Are there resources that patients can pursue right now rather than
these interventions that may be coming from the medical center?
Are there things that people can look into to help them stay on track
now for adults or children?
I can start with saying that the
reasonsare very different in different diseases.
And I didn't show the slide, which I use often is that you are really
piecing together puzzles where every disease has its own
reasons and you need to really... It's like precision
medicine. You need to identify what the reasons are for that disease
For children with acute lymphoblastic leukemia, where
forgetting to take the doses is the most common reason.
Making standard of care in terms of just taking their smartphones and
putting the timer on, which my kids do for their own meds
anyways,
would probably-- and having the parents involved would be the most important
thing, but it's very different in the adult population, and I'll
let them answer that.
I would add to that, that forgetfulness is not
probably the most substantive barrier in the particular
populations that I've focused on.
But when we have done qualitative studies, I would say that our
adherers, when they tell us how they do it,
often do mention strategies to overcome
forgetfulness. And those range a lot.
But the old low tech version is a pill box.
We actually were surprised by the number of people who told us that having a pill
box really helped because they could tell when they hadn't taken a
dose. Whereas sometimes when they looked back over their day, they actually weren't
sure. But if they had a pill box and the pill was still there, then they knew they
hadn't taken it.
And then phone-based, alarm-based reminders
are often mentioned. For some people, having a buddy
is mentioned. That's the adult equivalent of the
parent-child dyad. And then finally, a lot of
our wearables these days
do incorporate technology that can set a reminder,
medication specific or otherwise, and that is
useful for folks who aren't always near their phone.
So any of those, although I think sometimes a patient comes up with a better idea
than I do once I prompt them to come up with an idea.
I just would say from the colorectal cancer standpoint, I talked a lot about early
onset and the rising trends that are alarming there.
But in our patients who aren't in that demographic who are
on lots of other co-medications, this may be forgetfulness adjacent, but
the
challenge of the drug-drug interactions and when you can take
capecitabine in relation to meals or your proton pump inhibitor for your
acid reflux or whatever
that I think that sometimes gets very overwhelming like for our
patients in their practices, especially if they're older,
living alone, don't have a caregiver always available to
take care of them and help with them.
So it's not, I would say, as much of a forgetfulness issue, but just like a very
understanding real world compliance issue
in managing the other comorbidities that they're
experiencing.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, along those lines, I was just wondering if you could
comment if there is any studies on
whether treating the side effects would
increase adherence.
I mean, increasing treating the side effects, of course.
Yeah. I think that for us
having the benefit of a
palliative care and a supportive care group at our institution, we are
very big on when a patient comes to our institution
with a diagnosis of metastatic colorectal cancer, having them
engage early on
with our supportive care team at MD Anderson, and we very much tell the
patients, "We will treat your cancer, and these are another set of doctors who will
help us to help you to treat your symptoms." And we very much find
that aligning as a multipoint team
has been very helpful for our patients.
Also with pain, as patients don't feel well because they're in a lot of
pain from their advanced malignancy, they're less likely to take their
medications. So having this team member on board
has been a huge asset, and I can't,
no pun intended, support enough
having a supportive care team align with these patients as
they're going through this treatment.
I would add to that, that I suspect
as a clinician that for at least a subset of people whose
adherence challenges are side effect driven
it will help to more successfully treat
side effects.
I think we have a few barriers to doing that.
Number one, I think people often don't receive the message that are going to have
side effects, right? And they walk out the door with a pill, and then they're
surprised when they struggle. So I think normalizing
that this is a powerful therapy, but one that may also have side
effects is helpful.
And then having some member of your team, whether
it's a pharmacist, it's the oncologist themselves, the nurse practitioner is
often helpful here. It may have to be a different human
based on the practice setting, whether you're at MD Anderson or a small community
practice. But a human who has some training and
expertise in what side effect interventions actually work
so that they can provide effective therapy is important.
But actually, I think the critical problem is that we
usually don't know as the clinical team
when the person is having side effects.
And here, I think electronic symptom monitoring
is going to be very helpful. I think the problem right
now is that electronic symptom monitoring, which has been shown to actually improve
overall survival in advanced cancer patients, is being rolled out at many
institutions in the advanced cancer setting and in
IV therapies.In patients on active treatment with IV
therapies. So in the ASPEN study, um, Len Henry's
group is actually testing whether using electronic symptom
monitoring with feedback to the clinical team when a symptom
spikes is useful for endocrine therapy
adherence. And then we actually have a next generation trial under review right now
where we will actually combine the approaches of a counselor,
a motivational interviewing counselor, to tackle non-side effect
related barriers, um, and also to enhance sort of a patient's
capacity to be resilient to side effects, um,
with electronic symptom monitoring.
And we will sort of titrate exposure to those components
based on how much our participant is struggling in the
early parts of the study, very analogous to what Dr.
Bocchi did in pediatrics.
Hi. Yeah, I can certainly appreciate why patients would self-adjust
their medication because they have toxicity and don't feel well.
But how about the opposite, especially in the adjuvant setting where their
disease may or may not have been cured by surgery?
Do you ever hear the reason that, "I feel good.
I don't know why I'm taking this medication. I feel good, and I don't need it"?
Well, that's exactly what the kids do, especially the
adolescents. When they go into absolute denial, they feel like
they're feeling so good that this becomes a secondary
part of their treatment, and hence the need to make sure
that there's a parent involved in their care.
How about the adults?
Yes. In adults, I would say that this is partly on the clinical
team, right? Because we need to let people know that when a
recurrence becomes symptomatic, it's a really bad time to find out about it,
right? And I certainly have encountered patients who I
think had the misapprehension that if they did not
take therapy initially, they could sort of rescue
a metastatic recurrence with the drugs and start taking them then, and
of course, that's very much not true.
Um, and so I think one of the things to be clear about with
patients up front, um, I compare it to an
insurance policy, and we talk about why would you have an insurance policy
when your house is not burning down,
right? So I think just using clear analogies in lay language with folks
helps them get straight on why would I take this drug when I'm not
sick, when people keep telling me my cancer is cured.
I think in the solid tumor paradigm, that's a really important
construct to get across to people is why am I continuing on
therapy of any kind when my cancer is cured or
I'm cancer free? That's a
contradiction that I see a lot of people struggle with, and I'm betting that it's
probably true in colorectal as well.
I think exactly. You can kind of answer this on both sides of the spectrum.
I think with the evolving technologies with circulating tumor DNA, especially in
the stage two setting for colon cancer, um, we're seeing the
patients who are CTA negative. There's evidence that supports
de-escalation of care to observation.
So in those patients who are feeling well and otherwise have a good
pathologic diagnosis now further informed by a very favorable
negative ctDNA results,
de-escalation is
something we talk about frequently.
But I'll say just kind of in our clinical experience with the early onset patients,
what we hear from our patients is, "I am a 35-year-old with two small
kids at home and my career. Give me everything and more
because I do not want this cancer coming back." And we actually have to kind of put
the brakes on that and say, "We could be very well over treating
you and hurting you by doing that." Um, so in
the early onset, it's actually the opposite.
We're like, "Please,
I will do whatever I can to escalate to make sure this cancer doesn't come back."
One of the
really, I think, groundbreaking studies in the past year across all
of oncology was at ASCO last year, the, uh, Canadian exercise
study for patients with stage III disease that said if you just
increase your
activity level by 10 Mets a week, um, that
will significantly improve your likelihood, um, for your
stage III colorectal cancer not to recur and very much
gave nice evidence of exercise as being an
anti-neoplastic therapy that improves.
So we're trying to use that enthusiasm to channel in a healthy
route, uh, towards more activity, more exercise in our patients.
Interesting. Thank you.
Yeah.
Well, on that note, we're all going to exercise our way back
out
to our next session. Thank you so much.
Thank you.